[Music]
it's the real Avengers - I mean Captain
America Civil War I mean yeah the real
Avengers do don't get me wrong I like
Avengers - fine but this was the movie
that really felt like it was pushing
Marvel films to the next level and it's
literally just missing two Avengers and
it adds so many other characters that
you know just grid this is the real
Avengers - out of all the Marvel movies
so far I have to admit this might be my
favorite one Marvel films when they
started out were known for doing things
very different but after a while they're
starting to get kind of a repetition
people could recognize when they were
building up another Marvel film or when
there was a joke that didn't need to
have a joke there's a little bit of a
formula but every once in a while one
comes along to push the envelope just a
little bit more and this one definitely
does that Captain America has a lot on
his plate not only has he lost the love
of his life to old age man that's gotta
be a surreal thing to go through but
he's also trying to protect Bucky the
Winter Soldier because he doesn't think
he's really bad he was just brainwashed
constantly deal with the government
trying to tell him and his team what he
can't and can't do and even start
butting heads with Tony Stark who feels
a great deal of guilt for the people
that might have been killed in their
battles with more explosions and
assassinations keep popping up around
them though a choice is made to finally
stop the Avengers but half of them don't
want to particularly Captain America
mostly because the other half see Bucky
is dangerous and should be turned in so
it's a battle of heroes and ideologies
as the team is split and they constantly
go against each other trying to get
Bucky as well as figure out who the real
mastermind behind all of this is oh and
did I also mention Black Panther oh and
spider-man on the death of Tony's mother
oh and like a billion other things going
on this movie that are so massive that
the villain is actually just kind of a
wormy guy not even a big-time Marvel
villain in any other movie this would be
way too much and I would be so pissed
off at the Marvel villain is another
letdown but what makes this film so good
is every character's motivation is
completely understood it's perfectly
explained it's perfectly talked about
when an action sequence starts you don't
say to yourself why are we having this
action sequence you know exactly why
every time there's a twist or a turn it
doesn't feel like it's just the movie
trying to trick you it feels like it's
something else to motivate the
characters
or yes there's a bad guy technically
setting this up but he's almost
sidelined at the end the real focus is
these different heroes and their
different ideologies and you understand
them both relate with them both and feel
conflicted you still love both of these
sides it's not like in Avengers 2 where
you just say what the hell is Tony Stark
doing he's being a jackass or actually a
lot of the other Iron Man movies the
more I think about it you legitimately
get where he's coming from
you get where all sides are coming from
because all the characters are perfectly
established charming likeable distinct
and interesting well there is a lot of
talking and running around there's also
some incredible action sequences the one
at the airport unbelievable it was kind
of like watching the climax in the first
Avengers it's one of those fights you
never think you're gonna see on the big
screen at least not from Marvel comic
books you remember how big and epic they
were when you were reading them with
also the funny one-liners and the
distinct characters and the great action
sequences and here it is on the big
screen these fights are so amazing I'm
always shocked after all these years how
they can not only make these action
sequences so creative and so good but
how the CG most of the time can look
really good and even when it doesn't
it's still so imaginative these moves
are so clever and fast and what makes us
onboard with them is the fact that the
characters are so clever and fast if we
just did this action sequence and none
of them ever talked it would fail it
would go on too long it'd be boring but
because we do love these characters and
we love the way they interact off each
other and it's interesting to see them
fight one another it's one of the great
Marvel moments in my opinion it's one of
the best Marvel movies if not the best I
may still need a little time to look
over all the Marvel movies and see where
they're all going and what they do with
them but in terms of a Marvel movie that
was deep complex action-packed at great
characters had great laughs kept me
interested all the way through and I
couldn't wait to see what happened next
this is the movie that has everything
it's adult it's childish there's a lot
of sitting around talking there's a lot
of running around fighting it's funny
it's serious it's uplifting it's sad it
just has everything I would want from a
really great comic book movie so grab a
shield or swing on in because both sides
are ready to give you one hell of a time
you